Barcelona is a prugrasista city that is cifaré in madrid I mean I try the
parla el parla from madrid that is a city with savior and she is
representative madrid Prohid and cabusaltras dramatic and Spanish athletes
Asquedad before this cure before a racing You know what is the problem that
you do not govern for everything And in your words at the end there is what
I say I mean when you try the one in front because it has
less representation than your party.
you are not even committed to governing a city like barcelona
You are saying that in the end you are treating your opponents,
your political adversaries as less than residual simply
because they have less representation in a consistory.
I tell you barcelona today is governed by Mrs. ada colau who has put a
city at the service of ideology without thinking about the whole of her
barcelonian women And you yourself are portraying yourself with words to
your arguments Ideology is a level of noise isabelity is not replicated.